désolé pour toi jean edern est-ce que tu
regrettes des fois dans ta solitude des
femmes et des enfants abandonnés
bah je ne sais pas gelé je regrette tout
la vie est tellement regrets et lente
espérances
bien sûr des fautes que je lui connais
et tout le péché je les connais et d'une
certaine manière je les aime parce que
je veux dire je me repens et le plaisir
du repentir quelque chose absolument
sublime c'est une jouissance
supplémentaires jeudi à lâcher la halle
la jouissance même de la confession
tu n'as pas rond certaines fois d'avoir
des maîtresses qui ont l'âge de terre
qui sont plus jeunes bon mais je veux
dire pas du tout tu penses des fois que
ça pourrait tout à fait
ni ou plutôt ma mère mais très bien avec
tout le talent que tu as
est-ce que des fois tu te dis pas pour
tout tout seul avec toi même c'est
devenu un très bon cru de médiatique
mais un clown médiatique quand même je
pense que la société veut ça veut dire
que que dali picasso au passé pour des
clones et qui peut faire de temps en
temps une minute de silence en garde
bien sûr le silence ça finira différence
de pascal ne m'effraie pas